superlatives our monday football season
tradition the awards that we make up
they never get reduced to the form of a
trophy they never get written on a
plaque they never are even reduced to
any form of writing but we have fun
doing it although they do type them into
this sheet i don't know why for for the
like congressional record i don't know
anyway you get the first superlative of
today well let's talk about a game that
we haven't hit on from saturday you know
the the giddy up award to my man to my
boy blue giddyup you know giddy up giddy
what a shot my boy blue
i think i got a song for him now giddy
up getting up getting up it's my boy
blue
yeah
because that's what that was the other
night that was just that was damn
i mean the bills got physically
dominated in the football game they they
had no business winning that game they
won that game because of my boy blue
giddy up giddy up giddy up giddy up it's
my boy blue i mean just that's all there
was i don't know any other way to say it
i mean the plays he made at the end of
the half again there's only like two
guys in the sport i think that make
those plays it's rogers it's mahomes i
mean just some of the the plays he made
were absolutely phenomenal in the
football game the game was a little
concerning
as far as if you're a buffalo bills fan
you know because that's a hard way to
win a hard way to live you know being
the lesser team on the field but letting
this one guy overcome a lot of these
obstacles and of course they're gonna
have a challenge this week with the
baltimore ravens coming into town but
man you know great win it is there is
something to say it's a young football
team you get that you know now they know
what playoff intensity is all about and
all of that all you know all together
but that was a lot of josh allen on
saturday and a little too much out josh
allen for for my liking if you're
rooting for the bills and want them to
be a real super bowl contender
you know you see at the bottom of that
graphic it was the first bills playoff
win since december of 1995 my son and i
watched that game and and they they made
that comment or showed a graphic like
that at the end and he said my god it's
the first time they want to play off
games since i've been alive
yeah for a lot of people right i mean it
was 25 years ago and and chris
yeah i was looking for
signs of growth and maturity in josh
allen
as compared to last year in the
postseason where he was a little
reckless and you know that that the
touchdown pass that was the designed run
that went nowhere and he just decided oh
what the hell i'm gonna throw it to
dawson knox last year that gets picked
off right last year something crazy
happens there
but this year it works that's the
difference
from josh allen of 2019
to josh allen of 2020. there's a sense
you know i
i remember the first game of 2019 when
we were in chicago aaron rodgers had
some ugly duckling of a throw to the end
zone that was a touchdown
and and i remember we saying at the time
boy if mitchell trubisky had done that
it would have been intercepted there's a
different
vibe there's a different aura there's a
different sense and confidence
in josh allen
and that to me is the one play that
resonates the difference between last
year and this year and this year he was
enough to overcome
the incredible performance by the colts
450 total yards of offense and no
turnovers and they still lost the game
yeah i mean that you that says it i mean
that that's amazing
again and didn't i i thought i saw a
stat this weekend somewhere that it's
the first time ever that it's happened
we're a team 400 yards of total offense
no turnovers loses a playoff game right
i mean that that is amazing in itself
and i think that tells you how amazing
josh allen was you know again it's not
that the stats blow you away but it's
the timing of the big plays and the big
throws it's every big moment you go
oh he made a 25-yard laser throw
unbelievable oh he scrambled and made a
big run i mean you know leads the team
in rushing leads the team in throwing
leads the team in play making and to
your point michael you said i mean
you're spot on it's the old like the
game is just it looks like it's in slow
motion for josh allen right now last
year it was probably frantic and i don't
know but
confidence coaching you know some
success and everything now he's seeing
like a slow-motion movie picture now and
it's clear as can be and he's just
playing amazing football but man they
got to play better as a team this week
if they want to beat the ravens
but here's what impressed me more than
anything else
when you have been blowing everyone out
winning by double digits or more and
that snowball has been getting larger
and larger and it's coming so easily to
to do what you want to do and impose
your will on the other team and blow
them off the field all of a sudden that
bubble gets popped all of a sudden you
find yourself in a game all of a sudden
you may not be the better team on the
field that day to stay focused and
resolute and not kind of slump your
shoulders and give in or or get knocked
wobbly by a team that that isn't just
rolling over for you that's not easy to
do either you're right and that's a mark
of maturity and the coaching staff and
in the players because other teams that
would have stepped into that spot after
having it so easy for six or seven weeks
would have potentially slipped into the
it's just not our day mindset yeah
meltdowns or force the issue and make
another mistake and compound the game
i i think it's very real though
we've seen a lot of teams through
history have these great runs november
december get in the playoffs get punched
in the mouth and they're like wait what
you know things were all roses and
flowers it was great what's going on now
we can't we gotta fight for this one and
that did hit the bills at some point
during the game but they fought through
it they did and really it was the drive
and the decision to go for it on fourth
down by frank reich was the changing
point of the game you know frank wright
i love his game planning his aggressive
style of play calling all those things
but i don't know if he necessarily had
his best day managing a football game on
saturday you know that
10-7
you know phillip rivers on the road all
of those things i think i would have
just taken the 13-7 lead and tried to go
in and be happy even if buffalo does
score a touchdown okay great it's 14 13.
no big deal whatever uh but uh that was
the turning point of the game to miss
the fourth down fourth and goal and then
to have josh allen go down
and score a touchdown on the drive
before the half that was unbelievable
that that happened and that was some
swing of momentum right before halftime
and it was such a great play as michael
pittman jr worked his way through the
traffic and got open and it was just off
of his fingertips and how different the
game could have gone i'm gonna stay in
that same game because this merits some
conversation
on a day when it's easy to get bogged
down with other things this is the
threat level midnight averted award
this is about what would have happened
if the colts had managed to drive down
force overtime and win the game in extra
session or win the game in regulation
after that play
that resulted in not one
not two or three but four mistakes by
officiating the zack pascal he was down
he got up he fumbled the ball the bills
recovered it mistake number one
in real time the officials screwed it up
pascal was off the ground the ball came
out it should have been bill's ball
mistake number two
they didn't spot in new york al riveron
to be precise the necessity for a booth
review in the final two minutes of the
game that's mistake number two because
it forced the bills to say
timeout red flag no you can't throw a
red flag in that spot you have to call
the timeout if you don't have a timeout
the game just keeps going right you had
to call the timeout and hope that that
that would wake out riverrun up all due
respect and get him to review the play
mistake number three when they reviewed
the play they got it wrong they got it
wrong chris you know we joke from time
to time that there's a there's a magic
eight ball quality to replay review
especially last year with pass
interference nobody ever knew what the
hell the ruling was going to be from al
river on this was as bad of a replay
review ruling as i've ever seen zach
pascal's knee was off the ground before
the before he was touched and then the
ball comes out before he's back on the
ground clear and obvious it's clear and
obvious that's mistake number three and
then mistake number four is when they
try to clean up the mess afterward and
say the bills won't be charged a timeout
because the boom called the system was
that no no
because the referee is the one who hears
it yeah they didn't and then and here's
why the cults have caused to be upset
about it it's three reasons the bill
should be upset one reason the colts
should be upset the bills shouldn't have
gotten their time out back the nfl the
official should have said okay yeah the
timeout's gone we screwed up because the
bills used that timeout to adjust their
defense they didn't like the look they
had the colts could have scored a
touchdown that part of it actually
worked out for the league because the
last thing they needed on the back end
of that decision that stream of mistakes
was the cults winning the game because
if you think saints fans were a problem
two years ago oh my god you take that
and multiply it by a thousand and that's
what you would have gotten from the
buffalo bills fans
disaster averted there i mean you're
right if buffalo loses that game or it
goes into overtime and they lose and
something like that
i mean that would that's that's what we
would have spent everybody on
talk radio any tv show that's what we
would be talking about to start the day
it'd be the first 30 minutes on every
show the nfl there's a problem with the
officiating you know there's a problem
with replay first off listen it's quite
concerning and listen
the officiating this weekend was not
good in any
shape form whatever you want to talk
about it was the disaster and the
procedural you know effects and what
they did the amount of times for replays
how many times do we have huddles where
i think we're listening to al river run
but we're going to sit here and act like
we're having a conversation you know
we're going to go look at a replay of a
play where when we saw the replay it's
incomplete it's incomplete we don't need
to run over to the hood and go oh it's
incomplete like we know it it's a
hundred drunks who are almost blackout
drunk we know it's incomplete just say
it's incomplete and let's move on come
on hurry up this is a disaster but that
that has no excuse i don't understand
what went down there i really don't well
the fact that they couldn't see in real
time to stop it
that's that's what's concerning we all
saw it and we're like whoa that's close
oh let's see let's see and it to not
have that register and then have
mcdermott call that time out i mean that
to me that's concerning i don't know
what the hell is going on there
i haven't written this yet
because you know we had other games we
had to deal with we had our game
saturday night we had three games
yesterday but
there's a proposal i'm gonna make not
that they're gonna listen to me but i
don't care maybe other people who they
will listen to will see and say hey i
kind of like that maybe i'll make that
proposal as well they need to change the
rules for challenges in the final two
minutes of the half and in overtime
where it can't be activated by the
coaches why not have a standalone red
flag you can use in the final two
minutes of either half when it's
supposed to be automatic you can still
activate it you can still use it either
using the final two minutes of the first
half or the final two minutes of the
second half and then you get a fresh one
for overtime you don't get an extra one
you just have another one if you used it
if you used your emergency challenge
whatever they want to call it
during regulation you still get one if
you didn't use it you still get one in
overtime just to avoid a situation like
this where maybe al river on or whoever
is in that job in the future
is asleep at the switch you gotta have
break glass in the event of emergency
and you have to give the coach that
power and it's not that complicated it's
not that difficult will it be abused at
some point will you see a coach just go
ahead and activate the red flag late in
the game in the hopes that maybe he gets
lucky sure but that cost is outweighed
by the benefit of avoiding what we
almost saw happen on uh
because hey here's a well it just it
it's it it just
the system failed and uh it should have
been a fumble it should have been
buffalo's ball and and if the colts had
won the game yes that's all anyone would
be talking about today and that's the
last thing the nfl would want after six
playoff games yeah no that's uh i'm i'm
just glad it didn't come to that i
really am i did not want to start off
the 2020 playoffs with controversy
and you know a team winning or something
like that that didn't deserve to win
because we we blew
you know the procedure that that is that
there's no excuse for that there really
isn't and sky judge is the answer sky
judge is the answer something's got to
be spend the money you're right here's
the thing i i look
folks here's the thing we always have to
remember and it's easy to get caught up
in super duper wild card weekend it's
exciting best weekend of the year coming
up although super duper wild card
weekend pretty good in comparison
divisional weekend because you get six
games now
it's still a business
and at the end of the day they look at
budgets they look at cost they look at
benefit and someone
somewhere in an upper level of
management with the league looks at this
and says
if we spend all this money to have that
sky judge
how much better are the calls going to
actually be is it worth it to spend the
money can we tolerate the periodic oh
well stuff happens like that would have
been oh well stuff happens
is it worth it is it going to catch
enough mistakes to make it worth the
investment chris i think that's why they
resist it yeah i guess uh
something needs to be done to clean up
the game and increase the pace through
some of these moments that's the problem
we're having too many like hey the
fourth quarter was you know 20 minutes
long but the last minute and 50 of the
fourth quarter was 45 minutes long wait
how did that happen how did the last two
minutes of the game
take longer than the whole quarter
previously than that that that to me has
to get cleaned up too you want young
kids on nickelodeon to stay interested
well we can't sit there and just you
know look at slime while the referees
talk at each other for 35 minutes they
got to clean it up it was a bad weekend
for the referees all over almost every
game um you ready go ahead slide out
next
no no go ahead you're up i don't have
any other way to say this than just like
um
defense okay d d defense d d defense
because i i don't know i have nothing
creative and i didn't think about this
until right now but the rams defense
okay that's what i want to talk about i
mean wow
you know maybe this is a i wrote this
down the russianators that's what they
are the rams defense they terminate
russell wilson almost every time they
play him the russinators uh the rams d
what what can you say about that
performance i mean they're they're
showing they're proven to all of us
franchise quarterback does not matter
you can win with an average quarterback
if you build a damn team
and man aaron donald all over the place
i know he gets hurt
darius williams with the pick six off
the screen
but
look at these numbers when do you see 11
for 27 from russell wilson
11 for 27
holy crap i mean you never see that
174 pass yards they couldn't do diddly
squat in that football game they were
totally dominated by the rams physically
schematically emotionally
everything about it and i just gotta
give mcveigh a lot of credit runs the
ball
manages the game doesn't care so what
it's the ugliest game of the weekend
doesn't matter we're gonna do whatever
we got to do to win the game and just
the energy of that defense i find it
really fun to watch even though it's not
like the most exciting but ramsay donald
leonard floyd the way they fly around i
i really uh i enjoy watching them play
they gotta worry about aaron donald a
little bit now he had x-rays negative
but something's going on in that rib
cage i think we saw it last week he was
grabbing at his midsection exited the
game to get checked out
and uh yeah they're gonna need him this
weekend when they take on the green bay
packers you know i
i had one that that dovetails with yours
because
while we're praising the rams defense we
also have to be critical of
the seattle offense and my word is maybe
the jets were right all along
and it takes me back to when brian
schottenheimer was the offensive
coordinator of the jets and they were
pushing him for head coaching jobs
because they didn't want to have to fire
him
and brian schottenheimer is now being
quietly pushed for head coaching jobs
because the seahawks would probably
rather not fire him but there were some
comments from both pete carroll the head
coach and russell wilson the quarterback
after the game that if you look at them
closely and you juxtapose them
they're not real thrilled with the
offensive design and play calling chris
and that played into what the
russianators were able to do the
schottenheimer had something to do with
russell wilson not not playing at the
level and the offense not achieving what
it needed to achieve this is the
ultimate embarrassment for russell
wilson yeah to lose at home
in the wild card round against john
walford who was relieved by a broken
jared goff even a non-broken jared goff
isn't somebody russell wilson should be
losing to a broken jared goff he
definitely shouldn't be losing too well
you know the the questions about the
offense i think are real they're
warranted i think that's going to be a
conversation in seattle this year how
could it not be you know i mean they
they were a team that went a complete
180 down the stretch and became a
defensive football team and they were
all offense early in the year so that's
an issue you know listen this rams d
they're going to make a lot of offenses
look real crappy there's no doubt about
that but
with a talent like russell wilson and dk
metcalf and some of the other guys in
the seahawks they shouldn't be making
the seahawks look crap as crappy as they
do sometimes when they play the rams not
not that consistently to your point i
think you're you're spot on the the
seahawks are one of those teams where
listen i like brian schottenheim and a
lot of the things he does on the
offensive side of the ball but it's
another one of those where
you there's got to be another idea guy
in the building on the offensive side of
the ball maybe you bring in a pass game
coordinator i do i've always liked
schottenheimer's run game and the way he
approaches that but the pass game as you
can see
very stagnant there's not a lot that
goes on it's very basic schematics down
the field you know the rams i don't
they seem very comfortable all day even
blitzing russell wilson i don't think
they cared they just thought we kind of
know the routes and how they're gonna
run them so what if we have five guys
back there instead of six or we have
five guys back there instead of seven
you know and that to me plays into the
fact that they had a feel for that
seahawks and the predictability about
what they do in formations and
everything like that so uh i they
definitely got to go back to the drawing
board a little bit on that side of the
ball
yeah and uh
yeah it's another year gone for russell
wilson another opportunity to add to his
legacy evaporated and
you know we had the questions early in
the season will they pivot the offense
to suit his skills they did and it
worked until it didn't and i you know
now now i think we're left to ask is
russell wilson really in that top three
you'd put the top three right now
patrick holmes aaron rodgers and josh
allen in definitely one depth former
fashion definitely where's russell
wilson relative to those guys yeah that
that's a fair question i still think
he's right there he's not on those three
you know he didn't play the way those
three did especially the second half of
the year there's no doubt you're right
you know i think russell falls into that
next group of guys with desean watson
and everything like that desean watson's
really right there with those three guys
we just mentioned too really i think if
i really had to make another quarterback
list right now those three guys allen
rogers mahomes desean watson are going
towards the top of the four with the way
they played you know down the last seven
eight weeks of the year that was amazing
football but you know russell wilson i
think is the next guy there still he's
still phenomenal you know but i do think
you know what we've talked about is is
real
you know
russ
great offenses you kind of just said it
right there you know it was this great
offense early on and everything like
that and then it sputtered out and we
never saw fire it never really grew you
know great offenses always
pile on plays pi hey we've been doing
this play really good now we're going to
do this play off of that play it looks
the same but it's just a little
different and now we got to play off of
that play that we made just a little
different and and that's to me where you
know
the really great offenses just continued
to build the rolodex of plays and i
don't see that happen in seattle and
that's where i go you need we need some
other ideas in there uh we'll see where
it goes i'm still love russell wilson
he's still really damn good they just
got to help him out a little bit more
hey and let me tell you if they don't
at some point he's not going to sign yet
another contract extension at some point
they're going to have the issues in
seattle that they currently have in
houston that we haven't gotten to yet
maybe we'll get to at some point today
if not today we'll get to it tomorrow
because this desean watson stuff that
bubbled up last week out of the blue is
very very very real you have anything
else in your bag of superlatives today i
do i got another one and just you know
just a smidgen
just a little bit that's all we need
and when i say that just a smidgen just
a little bit i mean
just all we need is just a little
hollywood and a few throws outside the
numbers
and the ravens are a different team and
that's what that we we didn't get to
talk about this when we talked about the
ravens titans game because we talked so
much about the ravens defense and you
know we hit lamar and stopping derek
henry and all that stuff but man
i think one of the underrated aspects of
the game we know lamar jackson can run
and has three rockets up his butt and
can run by everybody we know that you
know what and he can throw the football
too he made a early bad interception
where the ball came out of his hands but
after that
man he made a number of big throws in
the football game and mike we saw them
throw the ball outside the numbers by
the sidelines a little bit finally
making the defense go out there and
defend some of that area of the football
field and it's really like they almost
they started doing that and all of a
sudden the run game started working we
always talk about you got to make
defenses defend the whole field and
that's one aspect that has missed from
the baltimore ravens i talked about it a
lot on my podcast last week but i really
like
not that it's gonna you know rewrite the
record books but there's an effort to
get hollywood brown the ball and there
seems like there's an effort or at least
an acknowledgement of we got to start
stressing that part of the field so not
everybody condenses in to stop lamar and
j.k dobbins in the run game i thought
that was huge yesterday just that little
bit of that pass game to really help
them get over the hump
one more quick one before we take a
break because we still have a lot to get
to but this one is the they should have
listened to bruce award because bruce
aaron's a coach of the buccaneers said
after
saturday night's win over washington he
actually hoped alex smith would be
playing in the game for washington
because he was afraid of taylor
heinecke's mobility
and he said he believes his defensive
players not the veterans but the younger
guys
kind of relaxed right and exhaled when
they heard that alex smith wasn't going
to play and he was trying to tell them
the other guy is going to give you more
trouble and you know what it makes me
wonder do you incorporate even more
taste some hill into the saints
offensive game plan next week if that
mobility is going to put extra stress on
the tampa defense but taylor heinecke
had a huge night 306 passing yards 46
rushing yards a couple of touchdowns he
had that great dive to the pylon
he got injured went to the locker room
came back finished the game off too much
too too late but at the same time
he he acquitted himself well he said
after the game that he he thinks he's
proven that he belongs in the nfl we'll
see if anyone agrees but bruce aaron's
definitely agreed he wanted alex smith
and not taylor heinecke on saturday
night well i get that you know you also
you know alex smith you kind of know
where the ball is going to go you know
you play a guy like a heineken who's got
a pretty good arm as we saw too he's
probably you know afraid of like oh man
you know they might they might dial up
some plays that we not really prepared
for with the alex smith offense with
heineken because they know he's got a
little bit more of an aggressive skill
set when it comes to throwing the ball
that way but that was unreal i mean that
was i don't even know i don't even know
how to like really quantify that or talk
about that that was like a movie type of
crap it was like hey we picked a guy off
the street and the biggest game of the
year what he hasn't done diddly squat
all season but he's going to be the best
player on wild card you know super wild
card saturday night i mean just amazing
some of the plays he was you know making
i don't know anybody
say it and you know it it really
i know they lost but that was the star
of the show you know i never felt like
they were going to win the game but you
just kept going
holy cow whoa this is still the game
they're hanging in there what a play i
mean it was amazing and uh just to add
on to that
a little concerning with the bucks
defense i'm sure that like emotional
aspect that you mentioned is real
but the one thing you see with tampa the
last few weeks if you can pick up their
blitz packages
man you can gash them in the pass game
and that's going to be scary this week
against the saints because there's some
holes in that tampa secondary
if you don't know much about who taylor
heinecke is or what he looks like or
sounds like you can see and hear his
interview with peter king on the peter
king podcast available now and chris i
had to stop myself a couple of times
this weekend
because when you're watching a playoff
game
there's that inclination when the
underdog is performing well
to start getting behind the underdog
at the expense of the postseason i know
chaos is fun until you're picking up the
pieces of an upset and the team that had
no business winning advances
to walk into a buzz saw the following
weekend yeah i was doing it with the
cults like hey oh this is interesting oh
my god colts knock out the bills and
that the two seed the first ever two
versus seven seed game the seven seed
wins are you kidding me no
we want the bills next week sorry colts
but for the standpoint of exciting games
we want the bills washington oh
oh tampa bay may be done tommy one and
done with the tampa buccaneers here goes
washington and then washington goes to
green bay not green bay where would they
have gone they would have gone watching
them would have gotten green wherever
you're right no okay washington goes
degrees oh no no no no they wouldn't
have they wouldn't they would have gone
to new orleans you're right either way
they wouldn't have gone past the
division all right it would have been
done cinderella's slipper would have
been shattered the following week it's
not worth it so that's the that's the
reality that's uh agreed
we you know we got the best eight teams
we do you know did i did i think that
cleveland was the best eight teams you
know last week no i mean really i we
should have saw the writing on the wall
there you know like we said in the first
segment the steelers
were the third best team
in the afc north we all fell in the trap
me you know all of us it's just oh
they're in the playoffs it's the browns
they'll win the football game it's just
stupid of all of us to fall in that trap
it really was we got fooled by one half
of football to think like oh they rided
the ship everything's good you know
shame on us to go that's disrespectful
of the game i think one half is going to
erase you know 15 other bad halves
there's no way you know and then the ram
seahawks listen that was a close game we
know it either way but obviously the
rams are a better team there's no way to
say it and man we got some match-ups you
know the number one scoring offense in
green bay versus the number one scoring
defense and jalen ramsey and aaron
donald versus aaron jones and devonte
adams ander rodgers i can't wait for
next weekend hey this last weekend was
super but what's better than super
because i feel like this weekend's gonna
beat that the what's phenomenal
legendary great i this this is great
divisional weekend let's start calling
it that right now
we don't need to add any more terms
because super wild card weekend will
always be super it will always be six
standalone games moving forward until
it's eight if they expand the playoff
field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports